buongiorno a tutti
esattamente otto anni fa in questo
periodo io entravo negli studi della rai
di corso sempione 27 a milano negli
studi radiofonici della rai e aprendo il
microfono raccontava una storia che mi
era caduta la storia era questa che
l'otto settembre del 1200 mila e 7
un giorno mi si era completamente
cancellata la memoria e da quel giorno
io non ricordavo più nulla di quello che
mi era successo per 33 anni della mia
vita e aprivo il microfono dicendo
esattamente questa storia mi chiamo
matteo caccia ho 33 anni e un anno fa ho
perso la memoria da quel giorno per me
ogni volta è la prima volta nell'arco di
un anno di programma che in 11 mesi di
programma io ho raccontato per un quarto
d'ora al giorno
la storia di un uomo che ha 33 anni
all'epoca scopriva il mondo per la prima
volta e quindi scopriva tutte le cose
che si scoprono nella vita da mangiare
un gelato per la prima volta fare il
bagno in mare per la prima volta a
baciare una donna per la prima volta e
poi il 31 di luglio del 2009
l'ultima puntata del programma io ho
raccontato come era andata questa storia
e cioè che la storia non era vera che
era un prodotto di fiction che io e un
altro autore avevano creato questo
programma proprio per fare quello di cui
parlava prima latino poco fa cioè
aiutare che ascoltava a sospendere a
sospendere la credulità e l'incredulità
e cercare di seguirmi mentre raccontava
una storia
alcuni l'hanno presa bene altri hanno
presa male
altri erano presa molto male in
particolar modo una ragazza che mi ha
detto non solo io ti ho creduto era di
queste parti non solo io ti ho creduto
ma di fronte ai miei amici che mi
dicevano guarda che non è vero io ti ho
difeso quindi mi hai fatto fare una
figura di merda doppia a me
davanti a loro dopo quel programma sono
andato da radiodue
sono andato in una radio che si chiama
radio 24 che la radio del sole 24 ore e
ho continuato a raccontare piccole
storie legate alla mia vita in quel caso
raccontavo le storie degli oggetti che
avevo che aveva avuto che aveva
racimolato nell'arco di una vita
il programma si chiamava avendo tutto
il punto di partenza lì era un altro il
punto di partenza era che mi aveva
lasciato la mia ragazza e avevo deciso
di vendere tutto e andarmene e quindi
vendevo tutti gli oggetti della mia vita
vendendo un oggetto venendo questo
tappeto raccontavo la storia di questo
tappeto la raccontava in onda e alla
fine della puntata c'è alle 16 e 30
questo tappeto era in vendita su ebay
base d'asta 99 centesimi
ho venduto 120 oggetti in questo modo è
quello che ho capito da quel programma
era che ogni oggetto anche se di valore
commerciale molto basso acquisiva un
enorme valore grazie alla storia che ci
attaccava in 120 oggetti quindi in sei
mesi di programma o venduto davvero di
tutto venuto un orologio venduto un'auto
venduto un tavolo venduto un casco
il primo oggetto che venduto è stato una
bottiglia di vetro di quelle col tappo
ermetico di quelle in cui si metteva la
quella polverina per rendere l'acqua
frizzante che avevo portato da casa dei
miei genitori a milano quando avevano
trasferito a milano e raccontato che in
quella bottiglia la mia ragazza mi aveva
lasciato una lettera in cui mi diceva
che mi lasciava e quindi volevo partire
da lì per vendere tutto era una
bottiglia che valeva probabilmente un
euro 80 l'ho venduta 19 euro più spese
di spedizione 9 euro e 50 a un ragazzo
che stava taranto e in questa in questo
programma ho continuato a raccontare
certo la biografia delle cose ma in
qualche modo la mia biografia che era
attraverso gli oggetti che aveva
posseduto e poi ai quali appunto la
smetta di raccontare storie legate alla
mia vita è legata a a pezzi di vita vera
è a pezzi di vita no ho cominciato a
interessarmi a un'altra cosa perché in
questi due anni sia durante amnesia così
si chiamava il programma della d2 sia
durante vendo tutto io cominciavo a
ricevere un sacco di messaggi è un sacco
di mail degli ascoltatori che
sostanzialmente è detta bene mira mi
raccontavano delle loro storie detta
male mi raccontavano i fatti loro
e infatti loro erano spesso molto molto
intimi e spesso erano molto molto
dettagliate e quindi io ho cominciato a
chiedere al mio editore che in quella in
quel momento era il sole 24 ore di fare
un programma in cui raccontavo storie di
vita delle persone perché dicevo lì c'è
qualcosa c'è sicuramente qualcosa nelle
storie grande nelle storie piccole nelle
storie
e successo ieri e in quelle enormi
successi 20 anni fa non è stato facile
perché perché gli editori in qualche
modo e non vale solo per quelli
radiofonici vale anche per quelli
cartacei sono convinti che le storie
delle persone non interessino le persone
o quantomeno non interessino se non c'è
un grande cappello che le copre che
abitualmente è un grande nome è una
firma è un autore è un conduttore
televisivo
abbiamo lottato un po insieme alla
redazione e alla fine siamo riusciti ad
andare in onda con un programma che si
chiamava voi siete qui quel programma
raccontava ogni giorno una storia
diversa di una persona diversa la
convocazione la koll che aveva fatto
alle persone era molto larga ed era
raccontami una storia che racconti
qualche cosa dite che se ve lo chiedo
adesso non mi viene in mente niente
ovviamente perché è una richiesta molto
larga ed è molto complicata cercare di
immaginare un episodio anche piccolo che
ci ricordi qualcosa e che racconti
qualcosa di noi li abbiamo capito un
sacco di cose abbiamo capito
innanzitutto che noi non siamo abituati
a immaginare la nostra vita come un
insieme di storie cioè come un insieme
di episodi legati tra di loro e che
probabilmente legati anche uno con
l'altro a distanza di anni e di molto
tempo riescono a dire qualcosa di noi
per cui quando abbiamo cominciato a
ricevere le storie è stato un bagno di
sangue
nel senso che io ho per un mese ho
temuto che non sarei riuscito a farlo
quel programma perché su 100 mail che
arrivavano c'erano cinque storie buone
tutte le altre non lo erano e quando mi
chiedono in base a che cosa decidi se
mandare in onda una storia oppure no la
regola è molto semplice cioè deve essere
una storia e per essere una storia ci
deve essere un inizio uno sviluppo e una
fine cioè deve essere avevo 15 anni è
successo a quella cosa è andata così
e finita così ci deve essere un'azione
che poi è tutto quello che noi vediamo
con andiamo al cinema quando vediamo un
film alla tv quando leggiamo un romanzo
o un racconto no c'è una cosa che
succede che si sviluppa nel tempo e che
ha una fine
mentre noi questa cosa non siamo più
abituati a immaginarla per cui su 100 me
che mi arrivavano al 95 erano
riflessioni sulla vita commenti romanzi
nel cassetto una marea tutti abbiamo un
romanzo nel cassetto racconti nel
cassetto
pagine di diario e noi invece avevamo
bisogno di storie
fortunatamente con il programma e con la
messa in onda del programma poi
l'ascolto di ascoltatori hanno capito di
che cosa avevamo bisogno e hanno capito
che ci interessava quel piccolo episodio
in quel momento particolare io ho
ricevuto da allora da voi siete qui a
oggi che invece sono in onda con un
programma che è in onda su radio2 alla
sera che stiamo a pascal ma che fa
quello cioè chiedere alle persone di
raccontare un pezzo della loro vita
io ho letto più di 12.000 racconti ne ho
mandati in onda circa 1500 e in qualche
modo raccontare queste storie di vita
io non lavoro con la fiction o proprio
mollato quel pezzo iniziale di cui vi
parlavo in cui mescola vola fiction alla
realtà lavoro solo con le storie di vita
vera non perché ci sia una forma di
voyerismo ma perché io io faccio
intrattenimento
non faccio nient'altro io lavoro in una
radio che è la seconda del secondo
canale pubblico della rai della di radio
rai che fa entrate è dedicata
all'intrattenimento in varie forme
ovviamente musicale molto leggero e no
io sono convinto che quello che faccio
sia in realtà una forma di
intrattenimento leggera l'editore un po
meno però troveremo un punto di incontro
prima o poi e da queste storie io ho
capito sostanzialmente tre cose
lavorando con le storie di vita delle
persone
la prima è che una storia se è una
storia veramente intrattiene cioè ti
prende e ti porta da un'altra parte
ed è quello che succede quando siamo
intorno a un tavolo a cena e uno
racconta una storia è quella storia ne
chiama un'altra è un po come quando un
argomento molto comune col quale succede
questa forma di osmosi el aeroplano io
vi racconto che ieri sono arrivato qui e
ho fatto un atterraggio orribile
sicuramente uno di voi viene voglia di
raccontare di quella volta che lei
arriva riattaccato quando stava per
atterrare l'altro quando dice che ho
sentito una volta un ragazzo a dire
durante un volo transoceanico
a un certo punto le hostess si sono
messi a piangere e non è stato un bel
momento lei ha vinto tutto con la sua
storia ma questo succede quando tu
racconti una tua storia è che fai venire
agli altri la voglia di raccontare una
propria quindi questa è una cosa che mi
hanno insegnato le storie e in qualche
modo
hanno cambiato il mio modo di vivere di
vedere le persone
una storia intrattiene ti prende ti
portano altra parte la seconda palla che
mi ha insegnato è che ti fa sentire meno
solo perché quella cosa che tu pensi
magari sia successa solo a te e ti senti
uno sfigato per quella roba lì non è
successo solo a te è già successo a
qualcun altro e magari è già successa
anche peggio di come è successo a te e
quindi in questo modo che si chiama
immedesimazione poi detta male però
questa questa forma di creare empatia
tre persone che non si conoscono e che
ascoltano una storia alla radio o che lo
ascoltano da un palco o che lo ascoltano
una sera in vacanza a un tavolo di un
villaggio dove non si è mai conosciuti
fa sì che io mi senta un po più vicino è
un po più uguale a con la persona e
soprattutto gli voglia un po più bene e
lui voglia un po più bene a me se io li
racconta un pezzo della mia vita
e la terza volta che fanno le storie
dall'altra parte invece è che calmi
erano il nostro il nostro egotismo
perché se io mi sento il più figo della
terra perché ho fatto con la roba sono
tranquillo che c'è sicuramente qualcuno
che l'ha fatta meglio di me e
probabilmente l'ha fatta molto più
grande e molto piu importante quindi in
questo senso raccontare e ascoltare
storie a ha cambiato la mia vita oltre a
tenermi molta compagnia perché io leggo
più o meno ce 100 storie di vita ogni
settimana ed è il pezzo più faticoso in
realtà perché c'è una forma di di dono
che una persona che sta a roma a napoli
a bolzano o a rovigo decide di mettersi
a un computer e di raccontarvi un pezzo
della sua vita e voglio raccontarvi tre
casi tre storie diverse che mi sono
arrivati in questi anni che sono per me
esemplari è la prima storia è la storia
di un un trasportatore di napoli è un
ragazzo che c'è alla mia età ha 40 anni
ne aveva 38 quando me l'ha mandata due
anni fa e apriva la mail dicendomi
scusami se faccio degli errori
grammaticali ma ho fatto solo la seconda
media e mi raccontava questa storia che
si intitolava il giorno in cui arrivò a
maradona
lui mi raccontava che era di una
famiglia povera di napoli che giocava
con un pallone di stracci in un
quartiere o comunque
insomma l'immagine che possiamo avere di
un sud le persone che hanno pochi soldi
in tasca e un bambino piccolo a degli
amici che tifano tifano juventus milan e
inter
e in quei giorni si parla di questo
tizio che sta arrivando in italia è un
piccoletto ed è forse il calciatore più
forte di tutti i tempi e tutti gli
dicono ma figuratevi anche paolo rossi
dovrà venire al napoli e poi venuto alla
juve è invece un giorno questo tizio
arriva suo padre lui mi racconta
disoccupato si fa prestare un pulmino
dallo zio che fa trasporto abusivo da
napoli a capodimonte prendono il pulmino
vanno al san paolo di napoli e san paolo
è pieno non so se avete presente con
l'immagine è pieno di gente e lui dice
si pensava che sarebbe arrivato con
l'elicottero sarebbe arrivato di corsa
questo tizio coi capelli ricci era
ancora magrolino il piccolo fa due
palleggi e lancia la palla e lui dice
questa frase un uomo che ha aperto la
mail dicendomi scusami per gli orrori
grammaticali
lui mi ha detto io noi tutti eravamo
così felici perché avevamo la sensazione
che quell'uomo fosse venuto a liberarci
e non sapeva dirmi da che cosa quando
gliel'ho chiesto però il telefono però
questa era una storia semplicissima che
k raccontava un momento della vita di
una persona che è che la che aveva
stravolto la sua vita
un altra storia invece è una storia più
semplice che sembra però tratta da un
film dell'orrore un tizio di cagliari
che ha una banchina e un giorno c'è il
mare splendida novembre vuole uscire a
pescare chiama i suoi amici i suoi amici
non ci sono e dice vabbè da solo non ci
vado
poi guarda il mare vede che piattissimo
dice massimi ma chi se ne frega parte
parte con la sua barkin a pesca un po
poi esce ancora si sposta ancora più al
largo e comincia a pescare comincia a
pescara la traina a un certo punto si
accorge che la barca è leggermente
sbandata e cerca di decelerare con la
mano con cui non è abituato a una
macchina con il motore fuoribordo e dice
uso la sinistra invece che la destra e
sbaglio perché semplicemente sono messo
al contrario di come sono messo di solo
da di solito la barca si inclina prende
velocità e io finisco in mare sono in
mezzo al mare sono da solo sono vestito
pesante e la barca che ha il motore
storto mi gira intorno all'inizio mi
viene da ridere
poi mi accorgo che non c'è niente da
ridere non c'è nessuno intorno a me
allora capisco che l'unico modo da
prendere la barca al volo che mi gira
intorno
cerca di prenderla una due tre volte e
sempre più stanco e in più l'elica gli
passa tanto così dalla faccia e dice beh
sono allenato ciò 30 anni torna nuoto
nuota per mezz'ora si spoglia perché è
molto pesante
dopo mezz'ora di nuoto alza la testa e
vede e la costa è lontanissima e la
barca è ancora dietro che gira e 15
attorno alla barca è l'unico modo cioè
per poter sopravvivere devo prendere
quella barca e quindi raggiunge la barca
dopo mezz'ora di nuoto
la barca questo punto allargato il suo
cerchio quindi solamente si sta
raddrizzando il motore aveva un certo
punto quando gli passa davanti riesce ad
afferrare la poppa e si accorge che c'è
il tubo che collega il serbatoio al
motore che un tubo più lungo del solito
riesce non sa come a prenderlo a
portarlo fuori bordo il tubo si sfila
per tutta la lunghezza fino a che per un
polo traina poi si stacca il motore
rimane senza senza benzina lui sale sul
monte sul sulla barca e fradicio ha un
freddo incredibile riesce a collegare il
motto del motore al serbatoio a il
panico di cadere in acqua a questo punto
sta seduto nella nella banchina come se
fosse un bambino di 5 anni terrorizzato
e racconta che quando arriva arriva da
lontano vede il suo cane viene da
piangere perché vede il suo cane e
quando lo vede lo abbraccia con tipo che
il cane non capisce perché lo stia
abbracciando perché non ha mai
abbracciato in vita sua
un'altra storia e della storia più
incredibile che mi arrivata è una storia
che aveva un titolo che si chiamava il
titolo sembrava già il titolo di un film
nel titolo era siamo vivi e la storia è
questa c'è un signore di 65 anni che sta
a torino e adesso la tomba del padre che
appena mancato e parla col padre egli
dice abbiamo spesso parlato e siamo
spesso chiesti che cosa c'è dopo la
morte
tu adesso in qualche modo lo sai se vuoi
farmelo sapere il giorno dopo torna a
casa e gli arriva una busta di un suo
parente di napoli che contiene una copia
de il mattino di napoli in quella
giornale c'è un articolo che racconta di
una ragazza del vvf che sta pulendo la
spiaggia in sicilia e ha trovato una
bottiglia di vetro chiusa con un tappo e
contenente un foglio dove ci sono
scritti 19 nomi e sotto la scritta siamo
vivi uno di questi 19 nomi e numeri suo
padre
e la storia è questa qua che suo padre
durante la seconda guerra mondiale che
la sommergibilista c'è tutto sulla copia
di giornale che li arrivate che mi ha
mandato ed era sul sommergibile che si
chiamava ascianghi che viene affondato
dalla marina militare inglese si muoiono
tutti tranne questi 19 marinai
giovanissimi che raggiungono la fregata
inglese salgono a bordo però sono fatti
prigionieri quindi li portano in africa
e ci rimarranno poi per tre anni ma
prima di tornare di di farsi portare in
africa loro vorrebbero raccontare a casa
che stanno bene è l'unica idea che gli
viene in mente nel 44 e scrivere su un
foglio i nomi e sotto la scritta siamo
vivi lui quando l'ho visto che quando
quando mi ha raccontato questa storia mi
ha detto chiaramente commosso per me
quella è stata una risposta alla domanda
che ho fatto a mio padre sulla sua tomba
è chiaro che una storia così ti fa un
intera stagione questo è un film anche
se non lo è è una storia vera e vi
racconto queste tre storie proprio
perché quando vi dico che la mia vita è
cambiata in qualche modo è cambiata in
questo senso perché perché se vedo una
persona che allo stadio piange di gioia
guardando un giocatore non penso che sia
un imbecille
perché se vedo un tizio che sale su una
banchina ed è bardato è un telefono
satellitare anche se a un 5 cavalli
non penso che sia uno troppo apprensivo
e se vedo una persona che mi dice che
c'è vita dopo la morte non penso che sia
non penso che sia uno stupido ed è ed è
per questo che secondo me raccontare
storie è un gesto politico nel senso più
puro del termine perché è mostra il
mondo in mille modi diversi perché fa
capire che la vita può essere vissuta in
mille modi diversi e ogni modo se è
lecito
ovviamente ha diritto di vivere in
questo mondo ed ecco perché secondo me
continuare a far sapere di noi a
raccontare delle storie nostre ea
raccogliere storie di vita delle altre
persone può può sollevare il livello di
temperatura umana tra le persone
non so cosa voglia dire quello che
quello che in quello che ho detto però
però è quello che provo è quello che
provo ogni volta che lei dovrà storia ci
sono delle storie che non fanno piangere
e mi fanno piangere come un bambino
anche se non dovrebbero essere
commoventi e credo che abbiano a che
fare con quella roba lì con il fatto che
c'è un livello di umanità nel momento in
cui una persona sale su un palco o
scrive un foglio e vi dice mi è successa
questa cosa che permette al mondo di
conoscersi un po di più raccontate
storie ascoltate le storie perché in
qualche modo le storie renderanno il
mondo un posto migliore grazie mille